sawtooth sweep frequency range 100 500.
all right oh
well hello there
i'm philippe cousteau the captain of the
submarine desiree where you are joining
us right now and i want to take you on a
tour of this incredible piece of
equipment
okay you caught me i can't lie this is a
replica of the desiree the real desiree
is docked somewhere top secret location
somewhere in the world this is actually
a replica at the youtube studios in new
york
um but we're gonna give you a tour
anyway we have brian right here uh brian
is manning the port aft four and stern
and top and bottom thrusters uh this
puppy can turn on a dime and is a very
impressive piece of equipment especially
in his hands we have ali over here next
to him she's in charge of radar and
sonar and ali let me tell you ally can
sense the difference between a pistol
shrimp and a goby fish from 10 000 yards
it's very very impressive uh right here
i'm standing in front of my center
console this is where uh i control many
of the functions in the ship where we're
going what we're doing things like that
you know captain things uh
very important captain things happen
here uh and then of course right here we
have ashland's corner we have ashlynn is
the source of our scientific knowledge
on board she is who we turn to for our
facts and and figures and also happens
to be our security
it's true it's true i'm always with my
trusty trusty knife
a real knife and actually this was
felipe's dad's knife that he brought
back from sudan and a lot of the pieces
around the ship the little things are uh
are things we brought from our house
that are part of philippe's parents
collection parents my grandparents
everybody that gathered from all over
the world on their expeditions but i
don't have to use this
for anybody to steal the ship right
that's right because
my favorite aspect of my center console
this is our anti-theft device very very
high tech i just take the steering wheel
with me we have niko here then at our
communications console incredible very
very tech equipment cutting edge much of
it top secret i can't tell you any more
about it but niko can hear a manatee
sneeze from 5 000 miles away next to
nico we have a bar this is where the
most important scientific experiments on
board happen at the bar right here which
rodrigo another oceanaat is manning
rodriguez our lingua speaks many many
different languages including i believe
uh porpoise and manta ray very two very
difficult languages uh he also makes an
incredible manhattan so i have to give
him props for that uh and then behind
him we have brad on sound you wouldn't
be hearing us if it wasn't for this
maestro of of of sound and then we have
kevin and mikey who are our two
incredibly talented filmmakers that have
been following us around all week as we
tell the story of the desiree its crew
and its exploits and then here we have
justin uh in a position that you will
usually find him in which is uh lounging
on in the lounge um he is hoping to
become a full-fledged oceanog at some
point but uh unless he spends more time
standing up and less time laying down
that is uh questionable whether or not
that's going to happen so we'll see
we'll root for him though uh that is the
desiree thank you all very much for
joining us for this brief tour and don't
miss the rest of our adventures at
raping story and the aquatic world of
philippe cousteau
full speed ahead